yes DJ Khaled went there he did perform
umrah but if I'm not mistaken before
after he went back to doing a concert
you know doing the music in Riyadh
actually
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes and we ask Allah to accept it from
him yes DJ Khaled went there he did
perform umrah but if I'm not mistaken
before after he went back to doing a
concert you know doing the music in
Riyadh actually sadly
um which is it's actually terribly wrong
in the Holy lands but now why am I doing
this video because many people think oh
he's gonna go back to sinning
okay let's suppose he does let's suppose
he does
how does that mean you do not come
perform umra I mean what logic is this
from shaytan to think oh I'm gonna go
and sin so let me not do a good deed
this is crazy this is not from Islam
even if you know you're gonna sin you do
it it's these actions that you do of
umrah Salah Quran these are the things
that's going to stop you from sinning
not I'll stop sinning you can't do
anything on your own fella or sister
yeah
you cannot do it on your own you need
the Quran and the Sunnah you need that
Allah has said that once you do that
that will stop you from sinning so you
need to take actions like Allah says
Salah keeps you away from Evil Deeds so
you need to think I need to go umrah or
Hajj or stop praying start reading the
Quran once you do that this is what is
going to cause you from leaving these
sins and we use that logic day today
when you get your place dirty do you say
oh no point cleaning them they're going
to get dirty again when you're sweaty
stinking or Bill yeah full out yeah
building yeah all day every day yeah are
you going to be like oh tomorrow I'm
gonna get sweaty again like I train yeah
oh I smell none I know let me just
carrying beans stinking until I'm ready
to clean my until I'm not going to sin
again well I'm I'm sure I'm not gonna go
to the gym again no I go again I'm gonna
clean myself of course I am why because
you're trying to be presentable in front
of the people
[ __ ] try to be presentable in front of
Allah by repenting because there are
going to be people on the day of
judgment where a group of other people
are going to see and be like you guys
seem like we do how comes you guys are
happy and we're doomed because they're
going to say we sinned but we repented
and Allah accepted our repentance never
forget that that's all I have to say may
Allah keep this
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Saturday for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shall be repeal the Lord
click the link and donate what you can